[Musique]
tous les trois ans la moitié des
sénateurs seront renouvelés et
renouvelle leur président en 2014 ils
sont élus gérard larcher déjà président
entre 2008 et 2011
la prochaine élection aura lieu le 2
octobre
le président assure l'organisation et la
direction des débats
il préside aussi le bureau du sénat qui
gère le fonctionnement interne et la
conférence des présidents qui fixe le
calendrier de la séance le président du
sénat représente l'institution
mais il a aussi des super pouvoirs il
nomme trois des neuf membres du conseil
constitutionnel et peut séduire les
sages si des textes de lois lui
paraissent contraires à la constitution
enfin le président du sénat c'est le
deuxième personnage de l'état garant de
la continuité de la république
il assure l'intérim si le président de
la république moeurs ou démissionne
cela a été le cas d'alain poher qui a
remplacé le général de gaulle en 1969 et
georges pompidou en 1974
[Musique]